- Hello, and I'm happy to
welcome you to the second
of this year's Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
here at the Whitney Humanities Center.
Each year, the annual Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
are organized in conjunction
with an upper level
undergraduate humanities seminar.
The lectures are made
possible by the generosity
of Richard and Barbara Franke,
and are intended to
present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience.
The Fall 2021 Franke
Lectures in the Humanities
has been organized in conjunction
with the Yale College
seminar, Mass Incarceration
in the Soviet Union and the United States.
And it's a tremendous honor
to present today's speaker.
Khalil Gibran Muhammad is
the Ford Foundation Professor
of History, Race and Public
Policy at the Harvard
Kennedy School and Director
of the Institutional
Anti-racism and Accountability Project.
He is the former director
of the Schomburg Center
for Research in Black Culture, a division
of the New York Public
Library, and the world's
leading library and archive
of global black history.
He is the author of the award-winning
Condemnation of Blackness: Race, Crime,
and the Making of Modern Urban America,
and a contributor to a 2014
National Research Council study,
The Growth of Incarceration
in the United States:
Exploring Causes and Consequences.
He is currently co-chairing
a National Academies
of Sciences Report on
reducing racial inequalities
in the criminal justice system.
And I know that that it's not an award,
but I regularly describe this book
as one of the most important
books in the 21st century.
It's about the United States,
but it is I think maybe
the best book, certainly
one of the best books
ever written, on the ideological
misuse of objectivity.
Khalil is a frequent
reviewer and commentator
in national print and
broadcast media outlets,
such as the Washington Post, the Nation,
National Public Radio, PBS NewsHour,
MSNBC and the New York
times, which includes
his sugar essay for the 1619 Project.
Also a remarkable piece.
He has appeared in a number of
feature-length documentaries,
including the recently released
Amend: The Fight for America, 2021,
the Oscar nominated 13th, 2016,
and Slavery by Another Name.
Khalil is an an award-winning
teacher at Harvard
and has received numerous
honors for his commitment
to public engagement,
such as Ebony Power 100
and the Distinguished Service Medal
from Columbia University's
Teacher's College.
He serves on several boards,
including the Vera Institute of Justice,
Cure Violence Global, and
the Museum of Modern Art.
And just before I hand things
over to Professor Muhammad,
he's going to speak for 45 to 50 minutes.
Then, Professor Snyder and
I, the co-teachers, conveners
of the seminar, will talk with
him for five minutes or so
while you put questions
and the question box.
And then, we will moderate a 45 minute
question session with your
questions to Professor Muhammad.
Okay, thank you.
- Thank you very much, Jason.
Thank you, Jason,
Professor Snyder, to Anna,
to all the people who
support this lecture series.
It's indeed an honor to visit
this seminar series, as well
as to be part of the Yale
virtual community this evening.
I have a lot of friends there, and indeed,
Jason mentioning the work of
the National Academy's report
on reducing racial inequalities
in the criminal justice system.
I'm also joined by Tracy Mirrors
and Elizabeth Hinton, two
friends and colleagues
who are working very hard on this report.
So, in any case, tonight's lecture is both
tied to the readings that
the students have read,
as well as some continuing
thoughts of my own
and borrowing from the work
of some of my colleagues
who continue to broaden our understanding
of the punitive roots of US society.
And with that, I thought
it opened with a little bit
of a context setting,
drawing on newer scholarship
by my colleagues, Kelly Lytle
Hernandez and Dan Berger
about settler colonialism, and
then launch into a bit more
directed focus on the
topic of tonight's lecture.
So with that, I'm going to
do just a tiny bit of reading
and then walk through the
material for this class.
So, in many ways, lots of
people have been focused
on the question of why the
United States, at this moment
in history, is the most
punitive nation in the world.
And of course, it's almost
rote to say that by population,
by per capita rates and by expenditures,
the United States exceeds
all other nations in how many
of its citizens, asylum seekers
and undocumented immigrants,
are under some form of
criminal legal supervision.
And over the past two decades,
there has been an explosion
of reports by government
agencies, nonprofits,
institutional advocacy,
organizations, so on and so forth,
exploring the dimensions
of what some would argue,
and while these empirical
and comparative data
on the size and scope of this system
and its many quote-unquote
clients will continue
to lie at the heart of
many of these reports,
only within the past
decade, I'd say, have people
really begun to take history seriously.
And so, answering the question
which I think animates
much of the seminar,
why the United States,
by comparison to, say, the Soviet Union,
is so punitive may be the most
relevant question to answer,
and not simply to document
its size, scale and scope.
And the challenge of
answering this question,
making it perhaps the most
difficult one to settle,
is not the lack of various
historical drivers or causes,
or even the range of possible
philosophical explanations
for how Americans have
imagined crime, sin,
human nature, and the
utility of punishment
going back to the Enlightenment period.
The problem is of course
that these historical
and philosophical
explanations have often been
least credible or
authoritative in explaining
mass incarceration among policymakers.
And this seems to me
to be a larger problem
about empiricism, about the relationship
of criminal justice
practitioners and their role
in providing technical assistance,
a kind of coziness that has
emerged over the past 50 years
with regard to the study of crime
and criminalization and
the actual practitioners
and law enforcement courts,
as well as in corrections.
And therefore, the disconnect
between the primary
knowledge producers of criminal justice
and just about everyone
else has grown wider.
And so, one of the legacies
of this disconnection
is the dismissal of history
as an important tool
to understand how we got here.
That, as I've already suggested,
is beginning to change.
So, let me set the scene,
a kind of long history
that I think helps to put
my more immediate concerns
for this evening's talk in context.
From the beginning, the
United States has been
what the historian Dan Berger
calls a captive nation.
In the summer of 2019,
of course, many people
within the United States
and in some places
around the world, commemorate
the 400th anniversary
of at least the landing of 20
or so Africans in Virginia,
and that this moment
represented a kind of attempt
to reflect on the fact
that in American history,
there is no moment when
European-descended people
did not use racialized
forms of punishment,
war or containment
against indigenous tribes,
immigrants or enslaved
people of African descent.
Settler colonists first use
the logic of elimination,
then turn to ideas of exploitation
to make way for their permanent residency.
Two and a half centuries
before the nation was founded,
and for nearly a century
after, the core institutions
of American democracy
and economy were built
on the land of the indigenous
and the backs of the enslaved.
As Dan Berger writes, quote, "Race,
"especially anti-black racism,
has been the primary modality
"through which this pairing of
colonization and confinement
"has transpired in the United States.
"Forcible consignment haunted black life
"from capture in Africa
through the Middle Passage
"and sale in the Americas."
And he continues, "Chattel slavery
"initiated a racial regime
rooted and confinement.
"Plantation slavery was as much
"a carceral force as
the early penitentiary.
"The historical institutions
of native reservations
"and African-American slavery
were the most durable legacies
"of a number of ideas and
ideologies that helped forge
"the punitive foundations
of American society.
"The frontier myth of
a virgin land waiting
"to be tamed and
cultivated by a master race
"animated much of the
colonial justification
'for native displacement and genocide.
"As generation after
generation of white colonists
"and later citizens moved
West, the choice to define
"native populations
and Mexicans as, quote,
"'savages or criminals by
law, custom, or practice,'
"rationalized the eventual creation
"of the nation from sea to sea.
"That Europeans did not
encounter the legal restrictions
"and physical constraints
of the old world and turned
"to religion to justify
conquest gave them a sense
"of legitimacy to what they
called Manifest Destiny.
"Philosophers and political
theorists from Adam Smith
"to John Locke and Thomas Hobbes
"helped justify conquest as
the march of civilization.
"By the 19th Century, a system
of federalism had evolved,
"which maximized various
states monopolies on violence
"to ensure conquered
indigenous and Mexican land
"would be converted to
private property by whites
"and capitalized by
chattelized black people."
And so, what is at stake in
this sketch of the early history
of the United States is precisely,
and let me pause here and say this slowly,
of the law itself.
At all times, a white outlaw culture
that rewarded brute force and strength
of arms against racialized
others unsettles basic
assumptions about how we are to understand
criminalization and
punitiveness over time,
that is who is counted as
criminal and to what extent
the state has used violence or punishment.
In Kelly Lytle Hernandez's recent study,
City of Inmates: Conquests, Rebellion,
and the Rise of Human
Caging in Los Angeles,
for which, among many
other accomplishments,
she won a MacArthur Genius Award,
she found a remarkably stable pattern
of criminalization and
incarceration going back
to a single carceral
site in the Tanga Basin,
once part of the Mexico named
for the native community
that originally occupied the
land for seven millennia.
What is today modern Los
Angeles, and here, I'll begin
to shift to this portion of the lecture,
if someone could just let me know
that you see only the slide
and not a bunch of noise
in the background, that would be helpful.
But if you do, here, why don't I do this?
Sorry for the pause, I know this is always
a little awkward when you're
working with one screen.
So, you should see mostly the slide.
What you see there is a depiction
of a 19th Century Los Angeles jail.
And part of what you want
to draw your attention to
is the seamlessness with which the space
of incarceration fits
within the larger commerce,
an economy of this growing city.
What she writes is that what
is today modern Los Angeles,
crime, punishment, emerged as the platform
for the racialized
inequities established during
the colonial era to flourish
in the Republic of Mexico.
By the 1820s, the new
nation's jails, prisons
and convict labor crews were overcrowded
with the historically marginalized,
the old colonial order,
largely a population of Natives, Africans,
mulattoes and mestizos, she writes.
As displaced landless
people, they were rested
on public order charges
ranging from vagrancy,
disorderly conduct and drunkenness.
She notes that in order
for manifest destiny
to have become more than a proclamation
or a simple fact of conquest by treaty,
then the law needed an infrastructure.
And let me note here that the arc of time
between charges of disorderly
conduct or drunkenness,
or what would later be
called status offenses
will have a powerful resonance
later in this lecture.
She notes that the law
needed an infrastructure.
The local jail therefore represented
the foundational structure, she writes,
of US conquest in Los Angeles.
She continues, it was how the
rule of law was established.
By 1850, the city passed
an ordinance that deputized
all whites on complaint
of any reasonable citizen,
and of course, the very
definition of citizen excluded
the very groups who were being
incarcerated, and established
racialized municipal chain
gangs and convict leasing
nearly a generation
before the end of slavery.
And so, let's talk about that
moment at the end of slavery,
and let's clarify a few terms
that I think are helpful,
if they've not already been made clear
in the context of previous discussions,
We talk a lot about mass incarceration.
I use the term racial criminalization,
and I want to introduce a concept
of mass criminalization
that may be less familiar.
And in this way, racial criminalization
is simply defining or stigmatizing
a racial group of people
as criminal, regardless
of guilt or innocence.
Of course, there's a
little bit of a double use
of the term racial here,
but the point being
that a racialized group
of people can then,
with the power of prescription,
be defined as criminal,
and it doesn't matter,
individual behavior,
it is a form of collective guilt.
Mass criminalization, and that is
using law and policy to limit the freedom
of a group of people
regardless of innocence.
And so here, we move into what
we will learn more quickly
is one thing to assign a
stereotype to a group of people.
It is another thing to use the force
of the law to act on that stereotype.
And then finally, mass incarceration.
And this is an important distinction,
because mass criminalization does not
by definition lead to mass incarceration.
Indeed, what we'll learn in just a moment,
or what you likely already
know, is that the era
of convict leasing in
the South and the era
of all-white juries after the
passage of the 14th Amendment
is a period of mass criminalization.
The law is intended as
a form of racial control
or social coercion within a
political economy of punishment.
The point is that people will accept
their second-class citizenship,
or they will accept
the coercive regimes of
sharecropping or tenant farming,
or other forms of extractive
work, having little to do
with putting as many people behind bars,
where obviously, we're talking about
in the mid-to-late 19th century, in fact.
The infrastructure of the jail
itself was less substantial
than was the prison farm
or the private lease.
But most people simply
didn't serve time at all.
They were scared into accepting
their second-class lives
working as free labor on a
cotton farm or cotton plantation.
And so, of course, the 13th
Amendment, which has come
into lots of scrutiny,
both for activists calling
for new amendments to strike
the clause of punishment
for crime, but also
some scholarly scrutiny
for a question of whether Congress
or the radical Republicans intended
to make the 13th Amendment
a kind of hollow gesture.
Nowhere in my work have I ascribed
that intentionality to the 13th Amendment.
Although I don't write about
it, it's certainly acknowledged
that this kind of legal
language or legal loophole
for forums of social and
civil death had been key
to the notion of hard work
as a form of punishment
and labor, even when prisons
were racially disparate
in the opposite direction
in the early 19th Century,
where they were simply all white prisons.
But that doesn't change the
fact that in the context
of the South and the postbellum period,
southerners made quite creative use
of this loophole for their own purposes
and enshrined in a set of
laws, known as black codes,
that African-Americans would be subjected
to an entire body of legal
jurisprudence that would be,
at its core, anti-black
and intended to be so.
The context of this is also a
kind of political revolution
that brought with it new
justification for ideas.
And these ideas are very
important because the interplay
of the use of various forms of coercive
criminal justice practices,
including the leasing of people
to private industry or the
threat of punishment as such,
also was wed to a narrative of blackness
that quickly attached to new forms
of data, essentially, to make the case.
But I wanted to highlight
here that the ascription
of criminality as a new form
of justifying oppression
is also the ongoing control over power,
the control over the power
of political representation
and participation, which,
of course, would come
with citizenship and
eventually be legislated
by virtue of needing to
pass another amendment.
That is the 15th Amendment.
And here, we just hear the
voice of one of the key writers
of this period, Hinton Rowan
Helper, essentially warning
the nation of what happens
if black people get to vote
and that their criminality is the basis
for that distract disfranchisement
and that distrust.
Negroes with their crime-stained blackness
could not rise to a plain
any higher than that
of base and beast-like savagery.
Helper presented his
collection of expert opinions
as an archeologist to use
his fossils to reconstruct
some prehistoric creature
for the world to behold,
with gratitude that had
no longer walks the earth.
In Helpers case, the
caption for posterity read,
terrible things await a nation
bent on handing ballots to beasts.
Seeing then end of the negro
does indeed belong to a lower
and inferior order of beings,
why in the name of heaven,
why, he pleaded with his readers,
should we forever degrade
and disgrace both ourselves
and our posterity by
entering of our own volition
into more intimate relations with him?
May God and his restraining mercy forbid
that we should ever do this
most foul and wicked thing.
Now, I know you've read chapter two.
This comes from chapter one.
But it helps to establish the baseline
for the ways in which
the notion of savagery
also led to extra-legal violence.
And so, if in the context
of the postbellum period,
if in the context for
an explosion of the use
of the criminal justice machinery,
or as Kelly Lytle Hernandez
has already suggested to us,
the infrastructure of the
jail as a coercive instrument,
so, too, were forms of racial terror.
And here is just one slice of
looking at documented cases
of lynchings across multiple states.
This number continues
to change as researchers
continue to find a new examples.
The range, of course, many people now know
was very arbitrary acts of transgressing
the social norms of white
supremacy in the South.
Because as much as the exploitative regime
of sharecropping was
intended to use the threat
of punishment to coerce
people, it also was wrapped
in the notion that people's own dignity
was a threat to those forms of oppression.
The simple fact of communicating
across the color line,
walking with one's back and
dignity wearing a uniform
of World War I, extended the range
of the kinds of things policed initially.
And so, we began to accumulate
not just the evidence
of racial terror, which
often was read as evidence
of a black transgression
or of a crime committed
by a black person, and in
the most extreme examples
used to justify lynching,
was the accusation of rape,
black male rape of white women.
And so, we began to produce
statistical evidence
out of what today we'd call
criminal justice contact,
police contact, convictions,
arrests, these sorts of things.
And so now, with the
distance of hindsight,
no one within the sound of
my voice would likely say,
well, of course, that was
all objective state activity,
and therefore the numbers were
a helpful guide to
understanding the levels
of antisocial behavior
within the black community.
But I'd caution you to so easily judge
those who articulated this
point of view in the past,
because it's precisely the
durability of this notion
that crime statistics have a
kind of truth value to them
that has helped not
only to justify the way
that the South first, and then really,
at a national scale organized
around these issues.
And even saying the South
first is complicated,
because the treatment of
antebellum African-Americans
as a criminal class even
proceeded the postbellum period.
But at scale, and within the
context of national debates
about the relative fitness of
black people for citizenship,
we first get to mass
emancipation in the period
after the Civil War, and then new kinds
of tools that take place, new kinds
of demographic questions and concerns.
This is the heyday of eugenics,
population studies are
happening in the Western world
in part to figure out how to manage
and contain the movement
and the aspirations
of the global South, as we
would recognize it today.
And so, Nathaniel Shaler
happens to be a popularizer
of history, a person who's
writing for the Atlantic Monthly,
the same magazine that
exists today with the same
kind of approach and
tone, which is to bridge
the gap between social science and policy,
and important questions
that people are trying
to answer with empirical
data for popular audiences.
And so, as a Harvard
paleontologist, he was a naturalist.
He had no particular skillset
for this kind of work,
but took it on as a translator.
And in his first article on this topic,
he essentially turned to
statistics as a way to resolve
a kind of problem, and that
problem was articulated
by Helper, which was to
say that many people assume
that southerners had a kind
of a bias towards ascribing
criminality and other racist
stereotypes about black people,
that they were primitive,
and that in the position
of being free, they were retrograding
to their quote-unquote
ancestral condition.
I don't want to get too much
into the present right now,
but to simply to say that
northerners had the reputation
of being sympathetic to black people.
And in the postbellum period,
these sectional divisions
about whose knowledge
was most authoritative
on this question of the appropriate place
that black people would fit in the social
and political hierarchy of the nation
came to be resolved by new forms of data.
And I'm dwelling on this point
for just a moment longer,
because it's precisely the
eugenics period where the notion
of objective crime data
or IQ test or birth rates
could all be forms of knowledge production
that would help policy
makers and elected officials
and other decision-makers
to make sure that they
organized society the most
productive and efficient way.
And so, out of the statistical data
that Nathaniel Shaler was calling for
came the first turn towards
the US census in 1990.
This census is an important milestone,
because it represented a
perfect generational cohort
for looking at the health and welfare
of African-Americans who had
been born outside of slavery.
So, if you're born in 1866, for example,
or in the winter of 1865, you've never,
quote-unquote, been touched by slavery,
and you could essentially
compare the health,
mortality, morbidity,
crime rates of people
who had never been as late
to those who had had been.
This kind of comparison
didn't actually happen
in the way that I've
described, but general claims
did occur, meaning that
people took to the 1890 Census
as the first authoritative
census after the Civil War.
One, sampling techniques
were problematic in 18 seven.
There was now the famous writer,
Thomas Dixon Page, who was
the novelist who's work,
The Klansman became the
basis of Birth of a Nation,
he and others called the New Issue.
And the New Issue was a younger
generation of black people.
Remember, someone like
W.E.B Du Bois is born
in Great Barrington,
Massachusetts in 1868.
He represents the New Issue.
He represents a person
who sees the possibilities
of his full humanity and being unchecked
and undiminished by
claims of white supremacy.
And essentially, this
animates his entire life
in corpus of academic work.
The other new issue, of course,
is all those entrepreneurial
and aspiring black people in the South
who are moving with freedom
and mobility in the South
and challenging, again, the
norms of white supremacy,
of which we saw the both
being defined as criminal,
and sometimes literally
being lynched by a lynch mob.
And so, the 1890 census
produces this new source
of administrative data that
points to a snapshot in time
that the population of
African-Americans is now 12%,
but they represent 30% of those
that could be counted as prisoners.
The raw numbers are roughly
82,000 total prisoners,
of which black people are about 22,000.
Within the 22,000, about
90% of them are men.
Now, because this is a
critique of these data,
the point is not to dwell on those
particular statistics,
to check their veracity.
It didn't really matter,
because people who turned
to those statistics, for
the first time who made use
of those statistics, who
saw themselves as innovative
in an effort to pick up where
Nathaniel Shaler had left off
by calling for statistics
as a way of measuring
the true racial capacity of black people,
one of those figures was a
man named Frederick Hoffman,
and in his work, Race
Trace and Tendencies,
which is really a work
about health differences
and health outcomes, because
in his day job as an actuary,
as the leading actuary
for Prudential Insurance,
his job was to make predictions
about life and death,
so that insurance policies
could be priced accordingly.
He also had a particular
concern about making sure
that working class white
people, including immigrants
like himself, he was a German immigrant,
would get a fair deal
because he recognized
that both nativism and segregation
of limited housing
opportunities, limited mobility,
various forms of
state-sponsored discrimination
directed towards immigrant populations,
was causing a problem for them.
And Hoffman's innovation in this moment
is to single out African-Americans,
to lift them out of what might have been.
And I'm not arguing a
counterfactual, I'm simply arguing
the debate that emerges
around Hoffman's work.
What might have been a robust sociological
or ecological argument about the nature
of premature death in the modern city,
what essentially he wanted to say was that
many immigrants are suffering from
exogenous social forces,
but black people are not.
And to make his point,
he made what we call
a white supremacist argument today.
He essentially argued
that black people by dent
of behavior and biology
faced only two options
in the race of competition
with white people,
that is the road to prison
or to an early grave.
And he was using the
data I just showed you
of the disproportionate
representation of black people
in prison as evidence for it.
Now, of course, you know
that the political economy
of punishment, which
we've already established,
makes it nearly impossible
to know how many
black people were truly
quote-unquote guilty
of a crime and deserving of punishment.
What we do know is that
generalized notions of the
structural forces contributing to crime
was an increasingly popular point of view,
pushing back against eugenics claims.
And so, here Hoffman
clearly positions himself
as someone interested
in progressive solutions
to the problem of crime and other forms
of antisocial or community-based harm.
He writes four years before Race Traits
and Tendencies of the American Negro,
the study of statistics of
suicide madness and crime
is one of the utmost
importance to any society.
When such an increase
has been proved to exist,
it is the duty of society to
leave nothing undone until
the evil has been checked or
been brought under control,
must come with the wealth of people.
We must be far from truth
lies, as long as we permit
to exist or accept inevitable conditions,
which year after you're
drive an increasing army
of unfortunates to
madness, crime or suicide.
It is the struggle of the
masses against the classes.
I like to joke that if Bernie
Sanders needed a speech writer
to illustrate the excesses of capitalism
and the harm that it does to people,
this metaphor of an increasing
army of unfortunates
would resonate very
powerfully with concern
about the premature death
of white people suffering
from both de-industrialization
and the opioid crisis.
So, Hoffman was not alone.
There were others, such as the socialist
and Progressive Labor Party
member, Harry Vrooman,
writing in the same magazine,
also before Race Traits,
in an article called Crime
and the Enforcement of Law,
that the whole problem of crime,
as to expressed in society
is summed up in the problem of poverty.
We have churches enough, schools enough,
moral sentiment enough,
to regenerate the world
in a decade where it not
for the awful pressure
brought to bear on
nine-tenths of the human race,
which all but forces them to be vicious.
And so, I want to establish a clear line
that in Hoffman's own
formulation of the use
of crime statistics, we have
two divergent explanations,
that the data of the
over-representation of people
in criminality when
applied to white people,
and European immigrants in particular,
represents the evidence of social forces,
of the structural economy, of
the excesses of capitalism,
which is why these people are
self-identified as socialists
and progressives who share
this point of view in common.
But Hoffman argued just the
opposite for African-Americans,
because as a racist and racialist project,
Hoffman pursued the data
to make the argument,
or I should say, to make
the data fit the argument.
Here, he notes prison and
arrest statistics from Chicago,
Philadelphia, Louisville, and
Charleston, and from states
including New Jersey and Pennsylvania,
confirm the census data
and show without exception
that the criminality of the
Negro exceeds that of any other
race of any numerical
importance in the country.
So, let's just take that first part
of the statement at face value.
It is true that the evidence
of the disproportionate
participation in the
criminal justice system
at the arrest level and
in the confinement level
show the highest rate
of disproportionality.
But if we were to take the same logic
as has been applied to
various white communities,
not by the eugenicist,
but by the progressives
and socialists, we say those
are the people suffering most
from the structural disadvantages
that happen in society.
But instead, Hoffman
said just the opposite.
When the Negro learns to
respect life, property,
and chastity, until he learns
to believe in the value
of a personal morality
operating in his daily life,
the criminal tendencies will increase.
And so, this notion of black criminality
or racial criminalization, then happening
in massive form, takes
on a life of its own.
And to use a concept
developed by Barbara Fields
called racecraft, essentially
the notion that new
racial logics or aetiologies
of race are grafted
onto ongoing projects of
racial control and power.
And so in here, the case is the
degree to which black people
are pursuing educational opportunities
becomes an argument against
their further education.
There is essentially all
sorts of magical thinking
happening here, which is
why I love this concept
of racecraft that Barbara
Fields comes up with.
But here's an example.
The Mississippi Governor
James K. Vardaman,
who is one of 11 Confederate governors,
the former Confederate
states, and minces no words
about the degeneracy and
inferiority of black people.
This is not a nuanced circumstance,
but what's fascinating
here is he does in fact
feel the pressure to defend
what is happening in Mississippi
on the basis of crime statistics.
And so, as much as there
is a robust, muscular
white supremacy happening on the ground,
there is still this
growing appetite and need
for a kind of national
agreement that southerners
may not be so bad after
all, if they can all agree
that the crime statistics tell the story.
And so here, Governor Vardaman says,
to school the negro is to
increase his criminality.
Official statistics do
not lie, and they tell us
that the negroes who can read and write
are more criminal than the illiterate.
In New England, where
they are best educated,
they are four-and-a-half times as criminal
as in the black belt, where
they are most ignorant.
The more money for negro
education, the more negro crime.
This is the unmistakable showing
of the United States census.
So, I want to disrupt the easy way
with which we might throw the
governor into a bucket of,
because even the governor wanted respect,
he wanted this form of
propaganda to be heard as a way
of justifying policies that were meant
to be modern and future-oriented
and not like his pro-slavery ancestors,
in the same way that we learned a lot
in international
comparisons about the ways
in which 20th century forms of segregation
and colonization are drawing on new ideas,
or at least ideas that
are newly ascendant.
And so, the black
sociologist Kelly Miller,
who's at Howard University at the time,
takes this argument on
directly, as does Du Bois
in the Study of the Negro Problem,
where he points out
Hoffman's biases by showing
that there is an appetite
within the nation
to accept without criticism
these early pronunciations
of black people as forever
doomed to be criminal.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in another example.
But here, Kelly Miller takes on
this exact argument at face value.
He says, okay, here's the argument.
Where legal processes are
acknowledged to be fair,
that is in the North, in
New England, for example,
where the negro has the fullest
educational opportunity,
which was more like fuller
rather than fullest,
he shows a criminal rate
three-to-four times as great
as his ignorant and oppressed
brother in the South.
And the conclusion is hastily reached
that education makes the negro criminal,
which of course is the justification
for rolling back educational opportunity.
So, Kelly Miller then goes
on to say, well, okay,
if black men are five times
more likely in the state
of Massachusetts to serve
time than in Mississippi,
maybe Hoffman and others
are onto something.
But what if white men are
10 times overrepresented?
Which it turns out to be the case.
And so, he asks this question,
did education make northern
whites criminal too?
Or shall we foster the bliss of ignorance
only when it is found under a black skin?
As you know from your reading,
Du Bois takes on similar
arguments by pointing out
in various European cities,
across from Munich to Breslau,
to other places, rates of
quote-unquote illegitimacy
and prostitution are higher
than is true for black women.
You also know that as much
as Hoffman places his target
on the backs of black men, he
also uses illegitimacy rates
and sexual transmission of
venereal diseases as evidence,
essentially, the statistical equivalent
for black women as sexually degenerate.
And so, these swirl of
arguments, of crime rates and
illegitimacy rates contribute
to what is happening
on the ground in cities
across the country.
In Atlanta, race riot emerges in 1906.
A French journal captures the
scene in this illustration.
And what comes out of
that is a powerful example
born out of the work of Ida B. Wells.
From your reading, you know Ida B. Wells
witnesses the lynching of three
of her friends who run a grocery store.
Out of that, she commits
herself to defending their honor
and to challenging the racial terror
of her hometown, Memphis, Tennessee.
Because she used her printing
press to tell their stories,
her printing press is
ultimately burned down
and she leaves town one
step ahead of a lynch mob.
She lands first in
Philadelphia, on to Chicago,
where she will dedicate
the rest of her life
not only exposing the
lies of white supremacy,
but building an infrastructure
of social service
and political activism for black women
in the club women's movement.
She's an early founder of
the National Association of
Colored Women, so on and so forth.
So, she's got this incredible career,
but she takes on these
arguments about lynching,
because having borne
direct witness to its toll
on black people, she is one
of the first African-Americans
who are challenging the
use of crime statistics
to make an argument
about black inferiority.
In this example, she happens
to be at a fundraising dinner
in Chicago where a speaker has just talked
about the recent events in Atlanta,
and a white woman named Mary Plummer,
who's a suffragist leans
over to her and says,
I don't know what we could say
about this terrible affair,
but there's one thing I can say,
and that is to urge all of you
to drive the criminals out from among you.
Have you forgotten that 10%
of all the crimes committed
in Chicago last year were by colored men,
less than 3% of the population?
It's a remarkable moment, because it shows
that the disproportionate evidence
of criminal justice
contact for black people
becomes a justification
for the instrumental use
of racial terror and violence.
Two things can be true at the same time,
nevermind the fact that we can't trust
that there isn't bias in the
logs and direct board
Americans in Chicago at this
time period, which we'll talk
about in just a few moments.
And so within the body of
work, that Ida B. Wells
is involved in, her most
seminal work, Southern Horrors,
which you've also read,
is a fascinating example
that at no point in these
histories that we are telling
did black people not speak
back to the ideologies
and the behavior that contributed
to premature death and
the justification of it.
And so, in this study, she does
a sample of Chicago Tribune.
She reads them, as you well know.
I liken her approach here, a form
of investigative journalism,
like the Washington Post
or The Guardian keeping
track of police killings,
because the nation is
not keeping track of it.
And so, she wants to uncover the myth
of black men as rapists as
justification for lynching,
which you also know in your
reading of Frederick Hoffman,
simply counted every lynching
as evidence of a black rape,
which by his own standards,
add to our standards,
simply wouldn't hold up to
peer review, so to speak.
But nevertheless, Ida B. Wells says
in the preamble of this work that out
of their mouths shall
murderers be condemned,
and she goes on to debunk the rape myth.
Now, of course, my colleague
Crystal Feimster at Yale
has done wonderful work in
pointing out that this rape myth
is as much a form of sexual control
over the behavior of white women.
And so, we have to think about
the gendered implications
of white supremacy, both as
directed towards black women,
but as well that this myth also functioned
as a form of sexual and social control
over white women's sexuality, as well.
She debunks the myth
by noting that only 31%
of even the allegation in those newspapers
was of rape, and she also goes on
to debunk the myth of black
female licentiousness.
In this way, she inverts
a racial narrative
by reporting on white
male rape of black women,
and among the many stories that she tells,
she tells one in particular
of a Nashville man
named Pat Hanifan, who had
outraged a little colored girl.
And for his crime, he was in
fact sentenced to six months
in the city jail, but upon
release became a city detective.
And this is not just our
2021 sense of outrage
at the hypocrisy in this, the
stories in her book in 1892,
precisely because she understood
it as outrageous, as well.
Nathaniel Shaler, who was a self-described
friend of the negro, a liberal at the time
who essentially asked this
statistical question in 1890,
which said a lot of this
motion, a decade later
starts to evaluate the
evidence that's come in,
and he takes a much more
centrist-moderate view,
that perhaps even out of
the work of Ida B. Wells,
he was inclined to
believe that the problem
of rape on the whole was more problem
of white male rape than black male rape,
noting there is less
danger to be apprehended
from them in this regard
than from an equal body
of whites of the like social grade.
And so, within this
constellation, I want to turn
our attention to, for a few
minutes, how this moves.
So, this is material that comes
from chapter three,
not out of chapter two,
because the continuation of
the story of Hoffman's impact
on setting the terms of how to
judge black people's fitness
for citizenship is also
born out by the legacy
of Hoffman and others in
pointing to European immigrants
and low-income white people as
being worthy of citizenship,
because their crime was not disqualifying.
And in this way, studies
like this, Frederick Bushee
on Ethnic Factors in Population of Boston
highlight the criminality
of the Irish and Italians.
There's a moral degradation
among Irish families.
For quarrels which are a serious affair,
for flashes of anger,
which mean a knife thrust,
must one go to the Italian quarters.
These are both expressions of the kind
of racialized logics that
apply to European immigrants,
but these are arguments in favor,
not a further criminalization,
but of assimilation,
which is itself a form of violence.
But within this context, the point is not
to be punitive, but to incorporate people
through fairer distribution
of public goods.
And so, people make the argument
that these are Americans in process,
these are fellow passengers
on our ship of state.
Hoffman himself engaged on this point,
but again, his agenda was
to single out black people
as exceptional, by
comparison to the Irish,
and exceptionally worthy of
divestment and not investment.
Du Bois, as you know, from your reading,
went to great lengths to
expose the hypocrisies
and contradictions of Hoffman's work
and the body of work that came from it.
He was roundly and consistently dismissed
as being biased towards his own people.
Include University of Pennsylvania,
sociologists saying that Du
Bois had a chip on his shoulder,
because surely his
accomplishments were evidence
not of white supremacy, but
of opportunity in the country.
Pretty remarkable.
And so, here Du Bois, who's
frustrated by a decade
after writing The Philadelphia
Negro and an essay
called The Souls of White
Folks, very expressively
describes the circumstances
of this contradiction.
Murder may swagger, theft may
rule, prostitution flourish,
and the nation gives but spasmodic,
intermittent and lukewarm attention.
But let the murder be
black or the thief brown,
and the righteousness of
indignation sweeps the world.
It is blackness that is
condemned, and not crime.
If it isn't obvious, that's where
the title of the book comes from.
Others looked at these contradictions
and begin to give voice to them.
Here's an editorial from the NAACP,
pointing out, as I like
to say, the two men,
the white man to the left
of the nattily-dressed man,
as well as the black man to the right
of his counterpart are our equivalent
of people sagging in
the early 20th century.
These are people who are
marked by a class identity
within their race, which
makes them suspect.
And the point here in American logic
is that white people see
this as individual failure,
whereas American logic,
white people see a black man
whose class position makes
him proximate to criminality,
as evidence of the race, which
is racial criminalization.
If they had that language at the time,
that's what they would have called this.
And so, that logic leads
to a predictable outcome.
On the ground in the work of progressives,
so the set of ideas to justify
reading crime statistics
is evidence of social economic
and political inequality
then leads to arguments such as this,
and this illustration from a
prisoner reentry organization
in Chicago describes the scene of a mother
raising her children potentially alone.
It's not clear if her
husband is in prison,
or down the street, or absent altogether.
What we do see is that she has
five kids, she's got a lot of babies.
And so, within the context
of eugenic concerns,
she shouldn't have had all
those babies in the first place.
But for progressives, the
problem here is that she lives
in a community of poor
people with broken windows.
And that leads to juvenile delinquency,
as two kids are fighting in the street.
Every poor community or immigrant slum
in the early 20th Century
in a place like Chicago
also has some kind of saloon
or bar around the corner.
It's hard to see in this image,
but it's the sign here where my mouse is.
And of course, every bad
neighborhood then and now
has some overpopulation
of police activity.
And here, some cop is dragging
some guy off the street.
But rather than make this a call about
personal responsibility or chastity
and morality, as Hoffman did,
these progresses in Chicago
made this an issue about larger structure.
So long as there are bad
tenements, sweatshops,
brutal policemen, bad jails, child labor,
dishonest and grinding employers,
saloons and gambling dens,
so long as boys are taught to fight
and allowed to carry firearms,
so long as fathers are
indifferent deserters
and mothers must maintain
the family by the washboard,
so long crime will continue.
What will you do to help this
association to prevent it?
And this story plays
out time and time again.
Jane Adams is the leading
social worker of the period.
She has tremendous power and influence
as a middle-class white
woman, social reformer.
She writes several books, she redefines
the problem of community
harm and juvenile delinquency
and social dysfunction,
not just as a problem
of society and the mistreatment of views,
but also not as one that is attached
to immigrant status or even
attached to nationality.
She is decriminalizing and de-racializing
the problem of white youth criminality,
because the statistics she's
facing are overwhelming.
15,000 youth brought before
the juvenile court in 1904,
she's talking about white kids.
She describes them as
stealing from their parents,
swiping junk, pawning their
clothes and shoes, doing, quote,
any desperate thing to get
the dope, as they called it.
She describes daily acts of violence,
of interpersonal violence,
as was true in the case
of this example of people using firearms.
So, the point is I'm showing
you the primary evidence
upon which we can see, up
close, how this is playing out.
And she also argues, so a Polish youth
shot an Irish boy in the head.
This tale could be duplicated
almost every morning.
What might be merely a
boyish scrap is turned
into a tragedy because
some boy has a revolver.
And she adds, we certainly
cannot expect the fathers
and mothers who have come
to the city from farms
or have immigrated from other lands
to appreciate or rectify these dangers,
nor could we expect the
young people themselves
to kill the cancer of
modern city conditions.
Jane Adams is an entire corpus of work,
and that corpus of work is also echoed
by the University of Chicago
and its ecological approach,
which saw immigrant
criminality and poverty,
or immigrant crime and
poverty, as evidence,
groups and the solution to
that was to disperse them
into communities with greater opportunity
to lift up their economic
base and to engage
in various forms of police
reform and other things.
Her work was praised for being
even poetic, within the
bounds of sociology,
which would be a rare thing today.
But of course, people
do win Pulitzer prizes,
which I guess is kind of the equivalent,
for writing a great work of ethnography,
such as Matt Desmond, so on and so forth.
Just to illustrate very quickly,
these politics of knowledge
and the violence of racial quantification
are also showing up and
black conservative voices.
Booker T. Washington is
one expression of this,
perhaps not as harsh as this one.
This is a man named
William Hannibal Thomas,
who you also were introduced
to from your reading.
He says that he's writing to
sociologists in the country
because he has firsthand
experience of what he's seen,
and as a black man, he
can testify with certainty
that it is true, black
people are degrading
into savage behavior,
they are savage at heart,
unable, practically to discern
between right and wrong,
intrinsically inferior type of humanity,
a record of lawless existence led
by every impulse and passion.
Really, the inferiority of
the negro in mind, morals,
judgment and character is
such that there is no doubt
that some very plausible
confirmatory evidence
of the justness of the
simian theory of human origin
might be derived from a close
inspection of his demeanor.
That's a mouthful, but he
basically said that he's convinced
by people really are
closer to apes and monkeys
than they are to human beings.
Of course, he wrote this around
the same time as a young man
named Ota Benga from the
Congo, literally placed
in the Bronx Zoo on
display in the monkey cage.
So, that Hannibal Thomas actually did not
present the kind of statistical evidence
that one could expect of such claims,
in the way that both Hoffman used them,
and even James K. Vardaman,
the Mississippi governor,
is surprising, because one would
have expected that his book
would have simply been ignored
by academics, but it wasn't.
In fact, by Franklin Giddings,
a towering intellectual
within the social science community,
the founder of Columbia University's
sociology department
and the third President
of the American Sociological Association
praised William Hannibal Thomas' book.
As a sociological study, it
is one of the most valuable
things to be put in the
hands of genuine students
of American conditions that I know of,
presents its subject without
an atom of the sentimentality,
which is so often proved a blemish
in many books otherwise most excellent.
And so, we've just seen an
example where one is praised,
in the case of Jane
Adams, for sentimentality,
and yet Hoffman, a black man
who has written without any
of the structural rules of
social science, is praised
for being objective because
he is a member of the race.
New York Times also gave it a rave review.
And so, to close, the echo
of this moment leads to
what will continue to be
various forms of redlining,
of instrumental violence,
of police control,
and eventually police taking on the work
of maintaining the second-class
and segregated lives
of black people outside of the South.
This is a scene from
the Chicago race riot.
I won't dwell on it, we can
talk more about it in a Q&A.
Black people in defense of themselves
are searched and stopped and disarmed.
Out of that report came a
number of recommendations.
These recommendations, I
won't read in this instance,
other than to say that they recommended,
led by a black sociologist
from the University of Chicago,
that crime statistics themselves
ought to be jettisoned,
because they were overly biased
and we're giving bad or false information,
evidence of their inaccuracy
and misrepresentation.
And the leading criminologists
agreed in two editions
that these statistics were
completely unreliable.
I'm going to skip over this example
in the interest of time,
we can come back to it.
So, we could ask the
question, what happened
to Bushee's Italian and Irish criminals?
How many Titan Americans
committed armed robbery last year,
Irish American burglars, or
in this case, we can't know.
The answer is that those
statistics disappeared.
The fact of their disappearance
is the evidence of the way
that this use of crime statistics,
as Professor Stanley would
describe as a former propaganda,
continues to drive discussion and debate
about the fate and future of black people.
Edwin Sutherland noted
that one of the reasons
why they stopped counting the
Irish and Italian Americans
is because they appear
to approach the same kind
of behavior as white
Americans, native born,
which is to essentially
say, as long as black people
could be singled out, or
Mexicans, or Chinese-Americans
or Chinese immigrants, for
having excessive crime rates,
and just to show you, this is crystallized
in Uniform Crime Reports,
which to this day
are the most authoritative
form of arrest statistics
as an indices of crime in the nation.
In 1933, when they began,
they pointed out negroes
and the foreign born should be watched.
By 1940, it is significant to point out
that the figure for native whites includes
the immediate descendants
of foreign born individuals.
This is a form of statistical white flight
at precisely the moment
where white flight is,
in fact, beginning to
happen in parts the country.
The Kerner Commission picks
up on the same recommendations
as the Chicago report,
which is why I didn't
read those in interest of time,
but they essentially
amount to better treatment
of citizens, more police protection,
because one of the other sides of the coin
of racist policing is
also under-protection.
They call for independent
citizen review boards,
a stop to aggressive patrol,
develop community policing.
A lot of this should sound familiar,
so familiar that even for Kenneth Clark,
who was famous for
having done doll studies
and contributing to the
end of formal segregation
in the '54 Supreme court decision
on Brown vs Board of Education,
notes that he'd read
the Chicago Riot report,
he read another one in Harlem
in 1935, another one in 1943,
and added that he kept reading
the same recommendations
and that it must be a kind
of Alice in Wonderland
with the same moving picture
we shown over and over again,
same analysis, same
recommendations and same inaction.
And so, here we are with
Bloomberg and Compstat.
The over-representation
of black and Latinos
relative to white in the
era of mass incarceration,
the ongoing use of violent crime rates.
The notion here is that because
crime dropped, incarceration must work.
You see an inverse relationship
with stop and frisk.
This was the defense of stop
and frisk as a massive system
of racial control and
police discrimination
that was ultimately ruled as such in 2013.
And what I wanted to show you
here is what collective guilt
looks like, because the long
legacy of Frederick Douglas
is articulated by the
former police commissioner
in New York, Ray Kelly,
who knows it doesn't mean
that people are not doing anything wrong
to the question of stopping
first racial profiling.
If you look at the statute,
it says reasonable suspicion
that individuals might be
about to commit a crime.
As a preventative aspect of this,
people say innocent, that
is not the appropriate word.
That's what collective guilt looks like.
And then he notes, this is standard
law enforcement practice around America.
I won't dwell on this, but this comes back
to the same kinds of
infrastructure of criminality
that we saw in Kelly Lytle's work,
drunkenness, disorderly
conduct, public urination.
The scale of Latino and black
stops produced little more
than summonses when people were stopped,
but 90% weren't even issued
so much as summonses,
because the vast majority
of people were stopped
for things that were not, in fact, crimes.
Ferguson had the same problem.
We know from the result, they resorted
to racist ideas to justify it.
And so, I'm reminded when we go back
to the racial terror era of lynching
that when we look at
police consent decrees,
since 1995, there were about 70 of them,
this is just a partial list,
it kind of looks the same,
It looks like how we might
look back on this moment
and see the same tally of state violence
in this moment as
similar to state violence
in the lynching era, which, of course,
in the lynching era was defensible.
And yet we're still having a debate
about the defensibility of
state violence in this moment.
And so, I close with one final echo,
and that echo is that we
could read the evidence
of opioid deaths in
the nation in this kind
of data visualization
that the New York Times
did a few years ago with the
evidence of wide-scale death.
Not too much of a leap to
note that that death itself
is wrapped up in various forms
of illegal drug consumption
and distribution and related
crimes that go along with it.
And yet, we are to understand as a society
that this tally of death in white America
is evidence of a public health challenge.
And Chris Christie articulates
this quite clearly,
addiction is an illness and we can beat.
If we give the people
the tools and support,
they need to overcome this disease.
If we choose to free people
from the stigma of addiction,
and recognize it as the
public health challenge
it truly is, we can help
people to reclaim their lives.
Think a great army of unfortunates.
We can find the true
measure of our compassion.
The investment we're
making will change lives
and get more people into treatment earlier
instead of the emergency
room or prison later.
So, this is a call for
disrupting the social conditions
leading to premature
death in white America.
And with that, thank you so
much for following that along.
Look forward to the conversation.
- Thank you so much Khalil,
and I loved you're adding
New York Times also gave it a rave review.
(men laughing)
History does not change.
So, first of all, I want to say,
everyone place your
questions into the Q&A,
and I will start collecting the questions
and we'll moderate them
as they start to roll in.
So, let's begin.
Tim, do you have?
- I mean, I had a thought, Khalil,
that I'd like to share with you
and see if you've had a similar thought.
In your book, you raise the
tantalizing possibility,
which we can't know
whether Frederick Hoffman
had red Ida B. Wells, and whether,
in some sense he was responding to her.
And in reading these two primary readings,
which Jason assigned along with your book,
I was struck by an really
strange structural similarity
that led me to think of
what Hoffman was doing
as a kind of scientific lynching.
And the reason I'm thinking about this
are two elements that I
draw from Ida B. Wells.
The first is, she points out
that what a lynch mob is doing
is basically discrediting the state.
A lynch mob is saying, these
people don't deserve the law.
By saying that, you're basically
pushing the state out of the picture.
You're pushing the rule of law
out of the picture in
the conventional sense.
And the other things she's doing,
which seems rather
courageous, or was courageous,
is that she's drawing
attention to the gender,
or the sexual aspect of it, right?
And then, if you read
the whole Hoffman thing,
you can look at what he's
doing as the same thing
that she's criticizing,
but on a much more,
in this empiricist way,
in a scholarly way.
Because he's arguing a lynch
mob would say one black man
did something on the basis of
hearsay or rumor, or whatever.
And he's saying the whole
black race does things, right?
And he's doing it on the
basis of this sketchy reading
of evidence, but it's the same mood.
And then, there's the same conclusion,
which is that these people
basically don't deserve the law.
They're, outside the law.
Maybe the state should act
to protect other people,
but the state shouldn't
act to protect them.
And there's this weird
dichotomy, which you emphasize
in your talk, where
Hoffman is basically saying
the state should be giving white people
good conditions for existence.
Meanwhile, it should be social
Darwinism for black people.
This funny thing.
But then there's also this
gender component, too.
Ida B. Wells is hinting, not hinting,
she's suggesting pretty
openly, that there's
an element of white male
anxiety about all this.
And Hoffman has an answer to that.
He's saying, look,
they're going to die out.
They're going to die out.
And when he was saying
that, I was thinking
of some of the nastier
performative parts of lynching.
When you say that a race is gonna die out,
you're also going, that's
an argument about manhood.
They can't keep it going,
they're gonna die out.
So, reading these things together,
along with your marvelous
work, I was struck
by this kind of odd structural similarity
between the way Ida B.
Wells describes lynching,
and then the way that Hoffman
goes about describing crime.
- Well, I think that's one of
the things that is surprising
in examining Du Bois' work, as well.
Du Bois is stuck trying
to essentially argue
against racialization by using the same
disparity data that
everybody else is using.
He doesn't have any more
evidence than the same sets
of quote-unquote facts about
disproportionate arrest rates
in the city of Philadelphia, for example,
except he has a different
interpretive lens
for how to we explain what's
happening to black people.
So, your point about the symmetry
with which these arguments
are constructed is partly why
this period is so important,
because we're stuck with the same form
of the argument about what to make
of what I would call statistical artifact.
A statistical artifact is a
trace of a set of interactions,
a set of power relationships,
a set of events,
and what to make of those
events, as you point out rightly,
Ida B. Wells is seeing
all sorts of things,
as you point out, white
male anxiety, she's seeing
different forms of victimization
on different scales.
But essentially it's this,
which is the evidence of
either a lynching or a rape
that that is the linchpin
of the entire discussion.
- I have a bunch of questions,
I'm going to try to hold them tight.
Let me see where to begin.
So, first of all, do I have it right
from the understanding of
the policing literature,
that one of the things
they did in response
to Irish and Italian American crime
was to make Irish and
Italian Americans police?
- That's one way to put it.
I think the motivation wasn't
to solve the crime problem.
The motivation was about image.
It was a form of
distributing public goods,
and in this case, civil service jobs.
Let me just qualify that
with one additional note.
In all of these groups, in these
liminal transitional spaces
between being the target of policing
to being part of the
police was usually a moment
when some Irish guy gets
hired to then go be,
(Khalil chuckling)
the special forces guy for
rooting out Irish crime,
or the Italian guy who does the same.
These histories are really fascinating.
I've forgotten the guy who
was the first Italian-American
who infiltrated the Sicilian
mob in New York City.
And then, there's Samuel
Battle, who was the first
black person who's assigned to Harlem.
So, there's a little bit of
truth to what you're saying,
but I think at scale, it was more about
distributing civil service jobs,
in which policing was one part of it.
- But did they do something
similar with black Americans?
Did make them into police?
- Yeah, this is why I
answered your question
about political patronage
and opportunity structures
rather than about crime control,
because in the case of
Italians and the Irish,
they moved into these positions,
what I'd say, at scale,
whereas for black people, they didn't
move into these positions at scale.
They were tokens, they were a little bit
of inside intelligence for
helping to certain crimes.
But in some ways, they were
a tiny sliver of patronage.
So, we never saw the same
upward mobility as a form
of political patronage for black people
that would have positioned them to simply
be the last immigrants to join the force,
if we're going to use that metaphor.
- Great.
Okay, so two more quick questions.
So one, I just want to check
by my teaching of Hoffman.
I regularly teach Hoffman,
just because I think
it probably holds the same
fascination for all of us,
the way the he believes he's
objective, yet it's so clearly,
you know, it's helpful
that Hoffman sometimes
to remind yourself he's arguing
that black people have less vital force
than white people, and
you have to remember,
there's no such thing as vital force.
(Jason chuckling)
So, but this massive
statistic, what you have,
the core of so many hot
department's arguments
are these claims that, in this
context, there's no racism.
So, he says, look in the North,
we know there's no racism.
In the South there's
racism, but in the North,
we still have these disparities.
So therefore, these
arguments of, oh, well,
this is a group that
doesn't have black people,
it doesn't face anti-black racism,
that seems, to me, core
to racist arguments,
not seeing the effects of racism,
Now, with the disparity and COVID deaths,
Hoffman would quickly conclude,
oh, black people have less vital force.
But now, people don't make that error.
Like, well, clearly that's environmental.
- Well, there are still medical
scientists and researchers
who are literally still searching
for the last remnants
of DNA that might reveal
the fundamental differences
in health outcomes.
The colloquial version of this
is that we're 99% the same,
and some people might say 99.9%.
But damn it, if that 0.1%
won't tell the whole story.
That's kind of how it works.
- And we see the same
exact thing with IQ debate.
People say, oh, black kids
adopted into white families
eventually do have an IQ deficit,
but they don't face racism,
because the assumption that,
(Jason chuckling)
So, there's an echoing
of Hoffman's arguments
I was wondering if you--
- Yeah, I would just,
- Yeah, go on.
- Yeah. I was just going
to say, one of the things
that as a writer I tried to do,
and this might be a curiosity to students.
I wrote about Hoffman
as someone who couldn't,
you know, my job wasn't to pass judgment
on Hoffman in analyzing his texts.
And one of the ways that
I focused on doing that
was to write from the perspective of him
looking forward, rather
than us looking backwards.
And I gave him a lot of
credit for his ingenuity
and innovation and his
willingness to defend
his point of view and to
search for the evidence,
wherever it led him in could find it.
And in a way, that's the
Du Bois' project also,
just to come back to Tim's earlier point.
Du Bois leaves Philadelphia
and goes to Atlanta
and spends a decade
turning over every stone
he can to take seriously,
maybe there is some evidence
that black people have a
particular predisposition
to various kinds of pathologies.
He doesn't find it, and he gives up,
and the only reason he gives up
is because the deck's stacked against him.
His arguments don't sit within a milieu
that is inclined to read any form
of black disadvantage of failure or death
as evidence that there's
something wrong with black people.
So to your point, the climate
in which academic research
and various debates about
racial disparities today
animate a lot of academic research,
and it tends to be a little
bit more disciplinary
in terms of who's on what side.
Economists tend to be more on
the side of individual agency.
It's a science of individual
in rational choice,
so that's not entirely a surprise.
And sociologists tend to be more inclined
to take the structural argument.
But there's heterogeneity in both sides
and sociologists weren't always as open
to these exogenous arguments
about black people.
- I'm gonna do a followup
quickly and then hand it over
to Tim, and then we'll go to questions.
That's a great point,
because it brings out
one of the things that's most criticized
in the current anti-critical
race theory, moral panic,
which is you're impugning objectivity.
And you've just brought out brilliantly,
I once I once had a Facebook
argument with Glenn Lowry,
who was like falling into this, oh, well,
there's objectivity and neutrality.
And I was like, wait, so,
economics doesn't have an ideology?
And he was like, oh
yeah, okay, you're right.
What a discipline is an ideology,
as you just pointed out.
But this is all being what's happening.
This point that any statistics,
any interpretation of statistics,
is going to be due through
an ideological lens
is being attacked as an attack
on science and objectivity.
- [Khalil] That's right, yeah.
- Tim?
- I mean, there's a dialectic
there, which is similar
to the dialectic I wanted
to mention before we turn,
and the dialectic is if you believe
that you're the kind of
person who's always objective,
that's a very deep form of subjectivity.
- Right, exactly, yes.
- There are a lot of folks
in these debates who think
that they're the kind of people
who are always objective.
- [Khalil] That's right.
- Which is a marker of their subjectivity.
I wanted to say something
similar about the law,
because I was really
struck in your presentation
and the way you went back and
forth between the sources,
and also in the Ida B.
Wells, Southern Horrors,
with an issue that I see when I write
about colonialism, and
actually about Nazi crime,
which is this notion that
we as a people are so legal,
we are such people of
the law that we can tell
when it's okay to make an exception.
We are, by definition,
such legally-minded people
that if we carry out a
lynching, ipso facto,
that must have been justified,
that state of exception
must have been justified.
And you see that you
see that state of mind
with the Germans in Eastern Europe.
It's very similar, this
notion that we are obviously
of a higher legal status
and the people we confront,
and because of our legal knowledge,
we know that it's okay
to make an exception.
- [Khalil] That's right.
- Because we're such legal people,
we know which people
are outside of the law,
we know when we can make an exception.
- Can I just echo that?
I wanted to make that point
in the preamble to the lecture
about the foundational
lawlessness of the law itself,
and to really nail the point
of a white outlaw culture
embedded within a legal culture,
that on the face of things,
possible to square these contradictions,
other than the way you just described.
And perhaps the more controversial analogy
would be that white collar
crime and financial crimes
in a culture that we have
today is very much about
rewarding people who can break
the law and get away with it.
And there's a kind of
culture of admiration
and respect for it, because
if everyone's playing
by the rules, then no one's gonna
make any money, because the market
is going to adjust perfectly
to perfect knowledge.
We all know the same thing, then we're
all competing at the same level.
But it's precisely the moment at which I
can exploit information,
which is often illegal
to exploit that information,
that I can get make money,
and maybe we catch these
people, maybe we don't.
I remember hearing a survey
of self-reported crimes
by financial sector
elite saying, basically,
have you witnessed or know
of a crime being committed
within the context of your work?
And I'm just going to guess
what I heard at that moment,
and people can look it up, but it was
a large number, it was well over 50% said,
yes, we've seen this all the time.
And that's just the point, right?
The rules are made to be broken
by powerful people only
to reinforce that they're
the right people to be
in control of the law.
- Excellent.
So, we've got a bunch of questions.
One of them feeds right
into the Muhammad worldview,
and one of them is the question,
the main critique you always get.
Which one do you want to start with?
- Let's start with the critique.
- Okay, so one of our students took
Professor Phillip Goff's course,
and of course, Phil, Professor Goff,
statistics are going to be used.
(Jason chuckling)
So, this student wants to say,
have you ever heard this question before?
How do we grapple with the tension between
simply knowing racism as
a truth of our existence,
versus using statistics as
a way to prove our reality
to those who don't experience
it, that is white people?
- Yeah, so I think this
is a question saying,
do we have to throw the baby
out with the bath water?
- Right.
- So, you know, I don't have a good answer
for this question any more than I had
a decade ago when I first wrote this book.
What I can tell you is that other people
who study comparative
societies that are rooted
in settler colonialism or colonialism,
South Africa, Brazil, France,
essentially tell stories
or have shown that in societies
where there is little administrative
or empirical data to
trace racial disparities,
communities have had a harder time,
who are the victims of systemic racism,
in making the case for those experiences.
And therefore, one could
argue that the other side
of the coin of racial criminalization,
vis-a-vis crime statistics, has been
robust social movement activism
in defense of black people's
civil and human rights, essentially using
the same evidence
against their oppressors.
And I don't know that I
can solve for that history
any more by acknowledging
that contradiction.
But if the question is,
how do we move forward,
it seems to me that that's less an answer
about whether we get rid
of racial crime statistics
as some kind of early warning system,
(Khalil chuckling)
and get to re-socialize ourselves
to a more universal understanding
of the very outlaw culture
that I've just described.
To borrow Tim's work here,
in a country that has used
forms of memory laws to
prohibit deep socialization
and learning about the
things that we are supposedly
never to forget, we keep forgetting
the same histories over and over again
and producing similar
outcomes in our society.
That, to me, seems to
be a first order problem
before we can decide
whether or not using race
as a way of measuring social phenomenon
is no longer useful in our society.
- Good, so okay, now let's flip,
continuing on the theme of objectivity.
So, here's a question on
the misuse and weaponization
of objectivity in modern America.
This is another, again,
a student in our class.
We have a mixed audience
of public and students.
So here, the question is,
how do you think crime data
is weaponized and debates
about policing in major cities,
especially with regard to
increased use of algorithms
and widespread use of
surveillance technology?
Okay, that's a bit of a
softball down the plate.
- Yeah, no, it's a great question,
and I wrote a new preface
to Condemnation two years
ago, and I had thought I
might read a little bit
from it, but I didn't.
But essentially, a couple of
years ago by way of anecdote,
Bill Bratton announced CompStat 2.0
at a conference that I was
attending in New York City.
It was a Future of Cities Conference
hosted by the Rockefeller Foundation,
and he bragged about CompStat 2.0 being
more predictive and not prejudicial,
more discriminating
and not discriminatory,
because this new algorithm
of hotspot policing
was gonna pinpoint exactly
the right criminals
in the community, sweep them away,
and make communities safe again.
And so, he even jokingly
said something to the effect
that it was like Minority
Report, the Tom Cruise movie,
where these precogs,
short for pre-cognition,
could predict the future,
see a crime happen, and then,
they'd send the police out,
Tom Cruise, for example,
to stop the murder before it happened.
And so, I write in the
preface that this notion
of a Minority Report as a
film is a double entendre
on the notion of a Minority Report
focusing on black and brown people.
So, to answer to your question, for much
of policing today remains committed
to the hyper-surveillance
of black communities,
predicated on the notion
that the statistics show
that there's lots of crime
in those communities,
and therefore policing ought
to remain at the levels
that it has historically
been and ought to be
the primary instrument for
delivering public safety.
Now, you didn't read this in the book,
and I talked a bit about it in the lecture
for this obvious reason, that if we
are to take history,
potentially, as some guide
to what might be possible
in the present, and people
can disagree about whether
that can happen or not,
policing was never the solution to all
the antisocial behavior
in the white community.
It's not now, and it wasn't
then after we got through
with the eugenics period and the period
of nativist reaction to immigrants.
So, the response was social investment.
So, we seem to be stuck on
allowing law enforcement
to define its bureaucratic imperatives
as our moral imperatives, and therefore,
it's going to use its
evidence as best it can
to make its argument, which
is to continue to point
to crime statistics as the proof.
But aside from everything
we might say to complicate
what does a crime actually
mean in the social context?
To use Tommy Shelby's work,
my colleague who makes
a very sophisticated argument
that as a philosopher,
essentially says, we can't
judge the crime in the community
if we can't deal with
the crimes of the state.
And so anyway, we could go down
the road there, but that's my reaction.
- Yeah, just an aside.
it's just so incredibly,
frustrating under-sells it to see
this repeat itself again and again.
Professor Hinton's first
book is on this topic,
she's speaking later in the
seminar, we're reading both
of her books, the removal of social aid
and support and just criminal solutions.
And again, and again, and again.
- [Khalil] And again.
- I won't ask you what people
ask me: what's the solution?
(Khalil laughing)
- All right.
So, another question.
One of the audience members is curious
about Hoffman's legacy,
in terms of the emphasis
of law and order and the war
on crime some 60 years later.
So, now we are getting into Hinton's
work.
- Well,
unless there's an add on to that question,
there is an interesting footnote
that isn't an obvious from what they read.
- Oh, go on.
- Yeah, so very quickly, Hoffman
couldn't be more interesting as a writer.
So, it might've been good
enough to read this book,
to put it in this historical context
and to see his contribution to the way
that we have this conversation today.
That's the point of chapter two.
But it turns out that Hoffman
is such a seminal figure
that his study of homicide in the country
makes him a sole source authority
on national homicide
statistics until the 1920s.
It really is until the federal,
the need for nationalizing
the collection of crime data
that Hoffman is the number
one source for making claims
about who's dying where
in what parts of the city.
And he's so credited for
it that he's award-winning,
so on and so forth, but one quick note.
His longevity is so
significant, and his place
in this sort of social
economy is so significant
that the National Urban League,
a civil rights organization,
invites him to a conference
in the 1920s to basically give
the statistics on homicide in
black America, because if you
want to know who's dying
and of what, he's the guy.
(Khalil chuckling)
And Du Bois is either
there or gets wind of it,
and he proverbially pulls his hair out,
because he's like this guy won't
go away, I cannot get rid of him.
So, to the questioner's point,
Hoffman lasts much longer than the 1890s
when this book is published
in his significance.
- So, I noticed in Aldean Morris's book,
A Scholar Denied, when he's
describing Dubois' conferences
in the Atlantic, they looked a lot like
year by year responses to Hoffman's book.
(Khalil laughing)
Is that right?
- I don't know--
- One is on disease,
one is on--
- Yeah.
I would say that a lot of academics
build their careers frustrated
with some body of work
(Jason laughing)
that they want to take down.
And I don't think it's too
much of a stretch to say
that Hoffman was a
consummate foil for Du Bois.
- Right, makes sense.
Right, but to continue the question,
the person wanted you to draw
parallels between the 1960s,
the Frontlash era, as it were,
to borrow Vesla Weaver's
terminology, and Hoffman.
So, how do you, yeah.
- Yeah, well, I'll just say,
and I'm gonna draw my
former IU colleague's work,
Nicole Siegel, who's written
a book called Violence Work.
And what's fascinating
about that work, a rich
archival study, is to look
explicitly at the relationship
between the academic
community of criminologists
and the clinical practice
of law enforcement,
and that these two things bleed
into each other beginning in the 1960s.
And so, there's a kind of
technocratic consensus between
a body of academic research
and basic law enforcement
that there's no room for
any critical distance.
Essentially, the academic
community is a handmaiden
to the law enforcement's need.
They need them to tell them,
how can we do our jobs better,
how can we be more effective at this work?
And while this might not
be an entirely a surprise,
it neutralizes and mitigates the kinds
of critiques that come from other
academic pockets and
other kinds of research,
such that law enforcement
is not accountable.
They can point to the
very research community
that they are both getting funding from,
from federal sources
increasingly, to do this work.
And so, everybody, in
the way that Hoffman is,
can argue for empiricism as the currency
for policymaking that is
fundamentally discriminatory
and is causing so much social
activism, that, of course,
Elizabeth is writing
about in her second book.
- So, here's the next question,
also from a seminar member.
Given the perception that, quote,
education makes the black
person a criminal, unquote,
how can we understand the
process of reformation
within the 19th and 20th
Century prison systems?
We've been going chronologically,
because it's a history class,
and that's apparently how you guys roll.
(men chuckling)
But so, we've read
Foucault, we started with
Austin Reed's book, and we've
been looking at reformation.
So, the question is how does,
so, there's moral
reformation through religion
and physical reformation through work,
but how does this discussion of education
increases criminality play
into prison reformation,
discussion about intellectual reformation,
in the late 19th and early 20th Century?
I guess to build on the question is,
is the result that the
reformation discussions
in prisons in late
19th, early 20th Century
exclude teaching, exclude prison?
I mean, it's really interesting.
I'm tempted to go to the
areas I know in the 90s
and removing prison education,
which happened in the 90s,
as it, education was not
important to reformation at all.
But is that a theme that, in
late 19th, early 20th Century,
was educational intellectual reformation
frowned upon as a result
of these discussions?
- So, let me cut to the first argument,
or the first a bit of evidence,
and then back into that question.
So first of all, what is
happening in the context
of reformation does not
apply to the vast majority
of African-Americans who
are still southerners
in the late 19th and early 20th Century.
Prison scholars, including
Rebecca McLennan and others,
see the broader period,
say between 1870 and 1920,
as a progressive project,
in Rebecca McClennan's words
as a kind of effort at manly citizenship,
but it is thoroughly
racialized in the direction
of what is required to give white men
a second chance through the
incarceration experience.
Mostly, that is about
work, so there is still
a carceral regime of extraction from men
in the name of rehabilitation.
But increasingly they get
the kind of programming
that we would recognize
in more modern times.
They get to publish newspapers,
they get, various forms
of arts and entertainment,
theater productions.
There isn't formal
education that I'm aware of,
and I've studied this period pretty well,
in a way of people
getting GEDs, for example.
But in anything's possible,
and so I don't want to exclude
that just because I can't
recall that being part of it.
So, there is a kind of a series
of intellectual nourishment
that comes through the arts
in other kinds of writing
forums, for people
who are publishing
newsletters in these places.
But these are places that
house 80% white populations.
There are small numbers of incarcerated
people of color in Chicago, New York,
Philadelphia, Los Angeles,
in these early days.
Maybe not so much Los
Angeles, let me hold off
on that precisely because of Kelly's work.
But in the places that I've looked
at these histories,
that's what it looks like.
It's the South that is
literally the Dark Ages,
and there's no effort to educate anybody.
So, what I point to in the presentation
and what you heard has everything to do
with the larger
justification for, at best,
a sharecropper's education in the South,
because too much education
would give people the tools
to question society,
and therefore that was
not consistent with the
racial project of control.
- Right.
It's kind of truly remarkable
when we think about
what happened in nine in the 90s,
when they removed funding
for prison education.
That that was the 1990s.
- That that was austerity.
So that was a version of neo-liberalism
pointing to a punitiveness
as a public good,
without encouraging forms of dependency,
and that is for the state.
And so, you could invest
in more punishment
as a form of incapacitation,
and maybe the logic
of deterrence, without making good
on any other possibilities,
like, pulling Pell grants,
pulling programming for education inside.
- Okay, so, maybe we have
time for one more question.
Let's see.
So, we've a couple more questions
on black education, but I think we've,
Let me see what question to close on.
Well, do you want to
talk about the legacy,
maybe tying some of these themes together,
I'm going to just jealously
ask you to end on this,
because I'm really interested
in this whole idea.
I'm interested in the
modern sort of racism
this stereotype that black
people, black Americans,
are anti-education, or view education
as white has been disturbing me of late.
So the question was, how does
this legacy of criminality
and education fit into, have a bearing,
on contemporary discussions
of black people on education?
- Yeah, well, there are a lot of them,
but there's one I skipped
over in the presentation.
So, in the interest of efficiency,
which of course is a major
theme in these arguments.
I'm going to show you
something I skipped over,
because I think it gets
at a little bit of this.
So, there's a section of the
book, it's not in the chapter
the students read, where
part of the rationale,
I mean, part of the emphasis
of the book and these echoes
is that so much of what
we might easily dismiss
as white supremacy required so much effort
at a performance of objectivity.
People wanted to be taken seriously,
people wanted not to
be dismissed as racist.
And that tendency today to
turn to empirical evidence
to end an argument or resolve a debate
is the same tendency to
say, I'm not a racist,
black people commit more crime
than anybody else, it's a fact.
That's the structure of the debate.
And so, part of the
structure of the debate
that we carry with us is that
people having this debate
about how to explain these
disparities a hundred years ago
was to then say, okay,
well, maybe we should look,
if education really
works, if education really
is just about opportunity
and we just need to extend
more opportunity, and
that will be the answer
to these disparities, I'm
talking a hundred years ago,
then people started looking
at the criminal records
of the alumni of various schools, HBCUs.
Theodore Roosevelt did it
at Hampton and Tuskegee,
as you know, Jason, from having
read the book, and it's remarkable.
Booker T. Washington
writes an article about it,
and he's basically saying,
you can count the alumni
of HBCUs and it's just a handful
can be counted in criminal records.
And what's interesting
is there's no equivalency
that I ever found amongst
various immigrant populations
that had shared this similar container
of criminalization for a time.
In fact, I'm not the only
one who pointed it out.
A guy named Ray Stannard Baker,
who was a liberal progressive at a time,
they wrote a book called
Along the Color Line,
and this was probably one of
the more progressive books
that could point to a
lot of contradictions.
It's cited in Condemnation.
And he pointed out, he
said, look, we keep counting
what happens to black
people in these schools
as some kind of evidence of
whether or not the school itself
is important or useful,
when we don't do the same
for places like Harvard and other places.
And his point is that if
we started to keep track
of the criminality coming out of
mainstream, elite white institutions,
and if we did an economic
analysis of it, there would be
untold damage done to individuals
and to society by virtue
of the alumni behavior
coming out of these schools.
Every financial crime that has
nearly destroyed the economy
on a scale of damage to
individual lives is incalculable
relative to someone who's a victim
of pick-pocketing,
burglary, or something else.
And by the way, homicide is a tiny part
of criminal offenses,
about 5%, violent crime.
So, most of what is crime and causes us
to have mass incarceration
is not killing somebody,
but something else, and
often something quite petty.
So, I point out that that economists today
are still using that framework.
They're still judging whether
a school is working or not
based on the crime rates of
black kids who attend them.
It's crazy, it is totally absurd,
as if the value of the public good itself
ought to be judged against whether or not
people engage in criminal activity.
Because what we
essentially are closing off
is the possibility that there
is nothing but association
and there is no causation,
and essentially the drivers
of antisocial behavior and criminality
are separate and apart from
whether or not kids are
school experience, but this is a legacy.
I won't give it all to Hoffman,
but he most certainly
advanced the argument
directly with regard to African-Americans.
- So, on the note that Harvard, Yale,
and Princeton lead directly to crime,
(Jason chuckling)
- Yeah, imagine a roster, I
mean, I'm not an economist,
but you could just take
kind of the most celebrated
white collar crime of the last 50 years
actually, names, sentences, crime itself,
and then do an estimate
on the actual damage
to people's lives, including
people killing themselves
because they lost a job,
or however it plays out,
- [Jason] Or a house.
- Or house, you name it.
- Or a mortgage,
then all the violent crimes that resulted
from that.
- Or domestic violence
driven by economic challenges, which is,
I'm not the social scientist, per se,
but this is a major
argument of social science,
that domestic violence
is often a consequence
of the difficult economic realities
that men, in particular, face.
So, that's the point.
The choice we make for the data we collect
and the arguments we make about it
is an expression of power itself.
And so, hopefully our
students will learn that,
and they will use their power wisely.
(Khalil chuckling)
- On that wonderful
note, thank you so much,
Professor Muhammad,
Khalil, that was wonderful.
Thank you for your vital work.
- Thank you so much for having me.
I hope to see everybody in person one day.
- Yeah, we would like that.
- Okay, bye-bye
- Bye, everyone.